[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver dans le 7-8 loisirs toutes vos
idées sorties dans le département merci
de nous retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro
tout de suite le sommaire de ce vendredi
22 septembre venez vous dépensez à lille
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
ce week end pour son événement sentez
vous sport
de nombreuses activités sont proposées
gratuitement danse badminton rugby nous
ferons l'eau où nous ferons le point sur
ces animations avec vincent couteau
responsable événementiel de l'île
loisirs et ali de loisirs toujours
mélanie poquet a testé pour nous le
parcours d'accrobranche tyrolienne et
passerelles dans les arbres sont
accessibles dès l'âge de 3 ans et pour
les plus grands possibilité de le faire
en nocturne avec chaque rom haïti
ces petites briques ont sûrement marqué
votre enfance les négos se révèle sous
toutes leurs formes dans une exposition
les 23 et 24 septembre
nous sommes allés à la rencontre du
président de l'association qui organise
qui nous a fait découvrir sa passion
mais avant direction versailles ou le
théâtre montansier fait ces deux cent
quarante ans cette année une exposition
lui est dédié jusqu'au 2 décembre aux
archives communales 180 objets programme
et photographies retracent l'histoire du
théâtre très marquée par des femmes
la première marguerite brunet dit
mademoiselle montansier qui a créé ce
théâtre inauguré en 1777 par louis saez
et marie-antoinette une de ces lettres
est à découvrir une pièce d'exception
selon le commissaire au micro de mélanie
poker alors il ya en effet des documents
assez exceptionnel certains inédits
comme une lettre de la montansier qui a
été offerte récemment aux archives
municipales écrites pendant son
incarcération
durant la révolution et qui est présenté
pour la première fois au public
dans cette lettre au moment où la
montansier est en prison elle essaie de
se justifier auprès dès révolutionnaires
et elle va inventer prétendre qu'elle a
était révolutionnaire avant la lettre en
accueillant les parisiennes au théâtre
de versailles durant les journées
d'octobre
sorti en 1932 il semble indémodable les
lego ont marqué toute une génération et
continue de faire des adeptes aux perray
en yvelines des collectionneurs organise
une exposition ce week end nous avons
rencontré le président de l'associa de
l'association breezy qui organise
l'événement nous a présenté ses
créations
un décor qui rappellerait presque les
aventuriers de l'arche perdue ce temple
égyptien c'est la fierté de son créateur
inspiré des temples de fil à et de
louxor
il comporte environ 5000 pièces de lego
quatre années de travail et de recherche
ont été nécessaires pour le réaliser
j'ai commencé par modélisés avec
différents logiciels
une première ébauche du temps pour
savoir les types de pièces qu'il fallait
acheter les quantités et après donc j'ai
commencé par construire toute la partie
avant de la façade je continue bien sûr
sur tout le reste
et au fur et à mesure j'ai amélioré
puisque au début le temple était plein
et
donc maintenant il est ouvert sur les
côtés pour qu'on puisse voir l'intérieur
les lego une passion commencé dès
l'enfance devenu un travail à part
entière président de l'association
breezy rémy organise une exposition
dédiée aux petites briques danoises
il se prépare pour le concours st un
petit module on appelle la vigne est
donc le but de représenter dans un
format assez réduit donc c'est le public
qui va voter pour la meilleure vignette
parmi les exposants le thème c'est de
représenter un sport et celle ci va
représenter de l'élève canada une
trentaine de passionnés feront découvrir
leur travail
une exposition pour les petits comme
pour les grands enfants pour les
sportifs ou simplement les curieux l'île
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
organise un événement ce week end samedi
23 et dimanche 24 septembre les
visiteurs sont attendus pour la 7e
édition de sentez vous sport 25 août au
responsable événementiel va nous donner
plus de détails sur le programme bonjour
vincent bonjour grille alors cet
événement c'est le plus important un de
l'île de loisirs ça chaque année un gros
succès c'est l'occasion de s'essayer
gratuitement à toutes sortes d'activités
oui tout à fait c'est un événement
national sentez vous sport on est en
place depuis sept ans sur l'île de
loisirs et ça permet d'essayer de beach
volley du badminton du rugby à 7 ou
rugby à toucher
du coccyx bon alors viendra un petit peu
dessus plus tard voilà ou du yoga par
exemple toutes sortes d'activités
du coup c'est accessible gratuitement et
vous l'avez dit c'est un événement
national donc porté notamment par le
comité national
ona olympique est donc partout en france
sont organisées des animations
alors l'idée de le faire à la rentrée
c'est que chacun puisse trouver une
activité a à faire pour tout le reste de
l'année en fin de compte oui exactement
cet événement c'est vraiment pour
inciter les français même les européens
puis maintenant c'est une semaine
européenne à pratiquer une activité
physique régulière en vue d'améliorer la
santé de tous et donc effectivement mois
de septembre un bon mois puisqu'on n'a
pas ses formes associatif mais tous les
clubs sont encore ouverts pour
accueillir des des adhérents pour
pratiquer justement l'année soit en
pratique encadrée soit en pratique libre
footings réguliers ce genre de choses
donc vous avez évoqué différentes
activités alors il y aura du beach
volley du badminton donc qui reste assez
classique mais il ya également quelques
originalités comme le coq sivola ou le
moule qui alors le maul si on connaît
déjà peut-être un petit peu mais le
coccyx bola alors qu'est ce que c'est
alors le coccyx beau lancer une activité
toute nouvelle un sport tout nouveau 1
qu'on a mis en place cet été et qui a
rencontré un grand succès non qu'on leur
met en place à la pour le grand public
ce week-end on joue avec des carrés de
tissu on voit 2 contre 2 ou un contre un
et l'idée c'est de tendre un carré de
tissu qui fera partir une balle de la
réceptionner leur tendre à nouveau et
donc on joue sur un terrain
l'équivalent d'un terrain de badminton
un petit peu plus long et le maul qui
alors ça par contre c'est finlandaise
tout à fait c'est qui finlande aise on
n'envoie pas mal sûr sur les plages
notamment maintenant elle était donc la
relance à un concours de ball qui demain
donc je vous invite à vous y inscrire
donc le principe c'est d'atteindre 50
points à sachant qu'ils ont fait tomber
une qui sait le numéro de la qui
équivaut au nombre de points sont en
fait tout mais plusieurs c'est le nombre
de qui donc voilà c'est à la fois
stratégique et à la fin je t'adresse
cécile vraiment à tous des activités qui
sont un petit peu de l'ordinaire à
découvrir et un mot également sur les
conditions d'accès donc ces activités
sont gratuites
il y a également un partenariat avec ski
parc payant celui ci le ticket est à 6
euros
mais il permet de découvrir beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus de choses exactement
ce qui part qui s'est installée cette
année avec nous sur l'île de loisirs qui
met en place notamment
de la cua karting du karting sur l'eau
des bulles géantes de l'agility golf de
un petit parcours aussi avec des ovaires
board électrique et du pilotage de
drones
donc ils ont une activité qui est
d'ordinaire payante
et pour ce week end là ils s'associent à
nous donc propose un ticket à 6 euros
avec un accès illimité à toutes leurs
activités
donc c'est un tarif réduit du tout à
fait et vous accueillez aussi un
ambassadeur du sport
will be man oui j'aime y est quasi qui
est venue cet été encadré une journée
avec des jeunes dans le cadre du village
sportif d'été et est là il revient
justement donc c'est une bonne occasion
de pratiquer du rugby avec lui il a
participé aux derniers jeux olympiques
de rio en rugby à 7 est donc il est très
accessible et signera si quelques
autographes donc profitez-en donc on
pourra découvrir tout ça également merci
dans son couteau en tout cas pour tous
ces précisions alors on le rappelle
sentez vous sport c'est les 23 et 24
septembre à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
tout le programme des festivités est à
retrouver sur le site internet
mais avant de se quitter vincent couteau
l'accrobranche fait également partie de
l'île de loisirs oui c'est un ono nos
principales activités
on a plusieurs parcours des tout petits
pour les 3 3 6 ans aux plus grands et
aux plus sportifs pour les plus
téméraires et pour notre rendez-vous
junior en plus mais annie poquet
l'attesté le rendez-vous junior
les parcours dans les arbres de branche
et loisirs attendent petits et grands
dès 3 ans vous pouvez vous prendre pour
tarzan à plusieurs mètres de hauteur et
mélanie a testé pour nous l'un de ces
parcours regarder et we came in je vous
ai pas attendu moi je suis déjà récupéré
avec mon baudrier à brancher loisirs il
ya cinq parcours à faire dans les arbres
on part au briefing
[Musique]
vous aviez bonjour déjà qu'est ce que
c'est que le parcours dans les arbres
alors c'est des petites activités qu'on
a mis à une certaine hauteur et les
enfants s'amusent dessus on des kabyles
et marcheurs des kabyles sorte de
plateforme en plateforme à quelle
hauteur maximale qu'un enfant peut faire
sur le parcours à partir de 6 ans fait
ils peuvent monter sur le verre de
monter à 3 m un trial bleus qui monte à
8 mètres et à partir de 12 ans et
peuvent avoir accès au rouge et au noir
le rouge c'est de vous mettre et le noir
16 mai on voit ce sens et les possibles
le début c'est ça
bon bah c'est parti premier parcours
l'initiation
[Musique]
attention comme ils y arrivent
oh mince non qu'est ce qu'on fait
[Musique]
parfait et voilà l'initiation est
terminée on va essayer d'en faire un peu
plus élevé ouais
[Musique]
j'ai fait deux sont mes trucs
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
jusqu'où cette forte
j'avoue
[Musique]
je viens de terminer la bleue oui je les
fais tout seul en tant qu'adulte mais
pour un enfant comment ça se passe pour
les enfants
nos torts et sont pas les enfants à
venir seul sur le parcours il faut
obligatoirement qui est un adulte
responsable soit là pour eux on les
oblige pas à monter dans les arbres mais
il faut au moins qu'ils les suivent au
sol les années scolaires de débuter pour
les enfants qui seraient intéressés
qu'on nous fasse entre copains et les
parents comment ça se passe et joue
l'ouverture c'est les mercredis après
midi samedi dimanche et jours fériés moi
j'ai testé ça y est j'ai fait au moins
un parent tour camille vous vois quand
sur le partant et bien justement ce
parcours il est possible de le tester de
nuit alors là cette fois ça s'adresse
plutôt aux adultes des 18 ans la
troisième accro night aura lieu le 29
septembre à partir de 20 heures un
parcours nocturne avec maquillage
phosphorescent et lampes frontales ça ça
reste du coup aux plus courageux
réservation obligatoire auprès de l'île
de loisirs et on passe maintenant à
notre agenda avec un dernier rendez vous
qui se passe rambouillet plongez au
coeur de la nature avec la cinquième
édition du festi photos de nombreux
artistes spécialisé dans la photographie
animalière présenteront leur travail
des stages et animations autour de la
photographie seront proposés
rendez vous dès ce vendredi 22 septembre
à la bergerie nationale de rambouillet
le 7-8 loisirs est maintenant terminé
merci de nous avoir suivis et mission à
retrouver sur notre site internet tv 78
points comme et en replay sur notre
application mobile je vous retrouve
vendredi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
10 il a passé un très bon week end riche
en activités
vous